hmm fallout 4s far harbour brings the
striker Batman modded out to launch
bowling balls it doesn't do an insane
amount of damage yet there are a few
things to know before you hit the lanes
so here's a quick rundown on everything
you need to know about the striker so
where is the striker it's in a bowling
alley of all places from far harbour
head south southwest to beavercreek
lanes inside to the far back right of
the building is the striker oh yeah now
we're catty or Nick tight make sure to
grab all of the bowling balls located in
here because as you're probably well
aware the wasteland is not flushed with
bowling balls however there is a way to
obtain infinite bowling balls if you
have the legendary fat man big boy which
you can pick up from arturo at the
diamond city market you can indeed
duplicate bowling balls that you fire
and that's because the big boys
legendary perk fires an additional
projectile what you want to do is swap
the weapon mod slots between the two
it's easy just go to the weapon bench
swap the striker with a standard
launcher then swap the bowling ball
launcher to the big boy and start sorry
yeah you're gonna want to double check
on what mod you have installed but there
BAM fire one pick up an extra spam this
until you get bored but you're really
going to want to swap back to the
striker because its legendary perk
brings eight fifty percent chance of
crippling a targets leg I know headshots
on ghouls are fun and bats wait I knew
it dude you're not sleeping Baker as you
can see the striker will decimate any
lower level enemies but when it comes
down to the higher level legendary jerks
you're gonna want to shoot them in the
legs I mean look at this stupid Dethklok
what's the matter babe oh alright
that's a strike mob crawlers no problem
they got plenty of legs to work with and
once you got them crippled have at it
with some melee weapons kuya again the
folder is not an amazing damage dealer
but the legendary jerk has given you
some problems the striker will put them
down